авдіївка в руїнах багато позицій
тут по суті не колами про піднялася обидва
станемо одним із ситуація різко
захотілося а ось уже п'ятий день постіль
вийняти люди цим для не травневих
політологи та висновок указка латте і
наставник по диван q&a всього можна було
вчити ось його стінки в серпанок ще
піддавайтеся вона історію конфлікту на
донбасі вже традиційно спа стріляється
шукала тебе червоне їй інша причина його на
як нами призначена важливо лише на
вихідних веду себе перший контакт mesh
трампом то путіним tramp peak відома сп
одягається на полі пшениці дно син версію
також москве одягається на волосінь
вчинок збоку сам що моя навчаючого
тебе шукала тебе і тесту я краху атоми
нові владні білок даних машин і так
вже телком чоловікові і ваша мета сигнал
європейцям звук русі і на вимикаючи
експерт adgex колоти відступала зірки
там порошенка та не машини, а пан бура
пригнув частиною дипломатичного ви
вирішення конфлікту теж москва йому поверну
хочу продемонструвати що все, що 3
травня з і сукня на сході України піт
контровим шукала цінні ієни спуді
ванну ворогові найкращий те що мінська відведення
навику ну ці
у каїві знову залу нала мінськ мертвий у
team не мати sky експерти не народити пар
годину на кого ти думала насті
нажаль альтернативи мінський у водяному
я свисну і в край доладно в тіла ти
Аліна містики його я б розряду повік
політично перевалу як міжнародний знак
Петренко
з дипломатична точка зору українська
сторона моя під бате рахунок м'яч за лише
вівсяне поле не там ще мінськ з без по
середній шанс для встановлення повноти
новому світу а там шукаємо мінськ зараз ти
на дипломатичній ігре щоб україна
виграв від шанс для теломери форм і
сметана не особливо суверенітету та алісуму
помітити
цього інтерфейсу експерти зауважують що
за мінськ slide примати саші задньої та
прості причини до нього при в'язанні
санкції проти Росії
як що ви знали що мінську воду йому
жив його у the'll це не ви любите
головний аргумент санкції проти кремля
люди з чоловіка за шлюб але tyene нас
система харчування покарають уже про
посилання санкції
angelo marani посилення санкції україна
реалістична загляну на мій будь не
виборі фронтиту в Нідерландах на майбутній
місяць і значить обіцяє є pro-t
щоб у за гален марек tvs консенсус
тему харчування на рахунку з кропу не
починав майбутньому морському всі труби
ти
c посил цієї допомоги ланка вдови а також
у монетарну допомогу мішкан сім
регіонів і кіно адже на контролі ванних
кривим територіях часто пса ще дуже
скептично ваше замовлення успішно
виробничої ситуації на донбасі
краще створіння будь-кого вигадають на
засіданні раді за він знову паршивець
буде сопити голову ванням україни на
правах на пусті але члена ради базу
каїф хлопець of типу в накладенні поспішаю
лютову